Okay. So we now come to the part where
we will create a new project for App Engine. You
create new projects using the developer console, which can be
accessed at this URL. This is a console that allows
you to configure many different Google services. But in
this course we will focus on the App Engine specific
parts. Go there and create a new project. We will
talk about installing the development environment a bit later on,
so don't worry about that right now. While creating
the project, you will be presented with the following dialog
box. Pay special attention to the project ID. The project
ID must be unique and it has certain naming restrictions.
Having a project ID you're happy with, though, can
be quite handy, since you can access your application through
a URL containing it. After you've created your project, this
is the URL that you can use to access it.
So in this example, the final URL will become
http://apt-octagon-533.appspot.com. See, that's the
project ID was this. So it's now time for you to go and create your new project.